you see there you go again not believe
that it's there it's saying that what is
there what you have that's with you is
true it confirms what is with you yeah
like I agree with what it says okay so
then that means that what is with them
is not corrupted right no it is
corrupted but what thean is corrupted so
the Quran is confirming corrupted books
yeah but you said that God wouldn't tell
you that corrupted books are true so
right here you're saying that Allah is
saying that corrupted books are
true would Allah ever tell people to
follow a book full of contradictions of
course not the reason why Muhammad came
into play and why he was the last
messenger was to correct all the wrongs
from the past that's why it was the last
Revelation okay because Muhammad is the
last prophet that okay so-called like
I got you I got you I got you okay I
hear you so Muhammad came to correct the
previous Revelations or the previous PE
scriptures because they have been cored
I wouldn't say I wouldn't say correct I
would say oh that's what you said sorry
let me rephrase that like it's the same
meaning of correct but I would say bring
down like the the official non like the
book that will never be changed until
the day of judgment was brought was
there a need for correction or not yes
yes okay let's say there was need for
correction I agree all right so the
Quran came correcting the previous the
scriptures that have been corrupted got
it so would Allah tell people to follow
corrupted scripture uh of course not
okay I agree with you I don't I don't
believe a good God will do that maybe a
deceit that's why that's why in the
Quran it says that the Bible got
corrupted by men well let let's let's
see if the Bible got corrupted by men
let's see this okay let's go with this
so this is chapter 2 verse 41 of the
Quran M it says believe in what I have
sent down confirming that which is
already with you B that which is between
your hands yeah we believe we believe in
the that's why I told you as Muslims
we're supposed to believe in the Bible
and the Torah because they were sent
down before us but it says that it says
that it's with the Jews and the
Christians presently in Muhammad's time
they have it can you read can you read
it again like the full scripture of
course of course so chapter 2 verse 41
and believe in what I have sent down
confirming that which is with you what
is your question say that again what's
the question my question is well you
already answered the question that God
would not tell you to follow or believe
in a corrupted book full of
contradictions but here the Quran says
that the books that the Christians have
and the Jews have that the Quran is
confirming those I get I don't mean it
as a God says we believe you should
believe in the past scriptures that was
sent down so basically take it as a
timeline we are supposed to believe that
God sent down the Torah at one point we
were supposed to believe that Jesus
reations that's what I'm attacking
that's what I'm attacking you're saying
that it was true at one point but then
later on got corrupted yes I'm showing
you that this isn't talking about the
past Revelation it's talking about what
they have it says it's the Quran
confirms that which is with you so they
have it presently it's not talking about
the past they have it now and the Quran
is saying that that what they have is
true yeah believe that it's it's it's
there it's no no not believe that see
there you go again not believe that it's
there it's saying that what is there
what you have that's with you is true it
confirms what is with you yeah like I
agree with what it says okay so then
that means that what is with them is not
corrupted right no it is corrupted but
what is corrupted so the Quran is
confirming corrupted books
yeah but you said that God wouldn't tell
you that corrupted books are true so
right here you're saying that Allah is
saying that corrupted books are true it
doesn't say that it's true it says that
it's with you no it says it's confirming
meaning so to to confirm literally means
to verify to to attest to the truth of a
thing to validate yeah to yes yes so
it's saying so when you confirm
something you're saying that that
something is true you're validating he's
what he's validating all right hold on
let me let's let's look at the let's
look at the definition of of of confirm
now now we gota now we don't know what
confirm he's validating I agree with you
he's validating but he's validating that
the Bible and the Torah existed no he's
he says that what is with them is valid
may may you please give me the the the
scripture you're reading chapter 2 verse
41 2 verse 4 chapter 2 verse 41 believe
in what we have sent down
confirming what
is yes if you continue reading it says
be not first to disbelievers therein and
part not with my Revelation for a
trifling price so if you continue if you
continue reading the scripture what what
does it say would you be able to
continue reading the scripture yeah I
you you just did it don't don't
disbelieve in my Revelation or try to
sell my verses for a small price and
fear me and fear me alone it doesn't
change what we're talking about but look
what I'm saying is what he said is true
yes he said be first to dis the
disbelievers therein and part not with
my Revelation correct so right what they
have with them is valid right yes but
what they have with them you're saying
are corrupted scriptures so you're
saying you're saying that corrupted
scriptures are valid I'm not saying that
that's literally what you're saying I'm
not because because this is what I'm
trying this is what I'm trying to
explain to you look look look I'm saying
yes those scriptures those scriptures
are are we recognize them to be able to
recognize something doesn't mean it's
validated or not valid s let's use the
words that the Quran uses it doesn't say
we recognize what you have it doesn't
say what you have exists it says the
Quan
confirms what you have it confirms it
that means that what you have is true
it's valid this is this is the key Point
you're missing he says he says believe
in which I reveal right the Quran why
why should they believe in the Quran
according to the verse confirming that
which ye possesses all already of the
scripture so what's the reason why these
people who have the scripture why should
they believe in the Quran that's that's
sent down why because no because of the
Bible and the Torah boom so so the Quran
is saying that you should believe in the
Quran people of the book because the
Quran lines up with the scriptures you
already have right so they should
believe the Quran too but you're picking
this is It's 2 plus 2 equals four man no
no no I I agree with you I'm not I'm not
I'm not disagreeing you you don't agree
with me because you're saying that what
they have is actually corrupted
but so if you're going to that okay I've
made I've made a mistake this is what
I'm going to retract okay I've made a
mistake because in fact that Muhammad
believed that the Bible in his time was
authentic beautiful yes you got it this
is what I agree you got oh my gosh you
got it you actually got it yes Muhammad
believed that the Bible in his time was
authentic you got it bro absolutely
abely so for a Muslim to try to come and
say that the Bible is
corrupted after after Muhammad's time
okay let's go with that now let's so
let's go with that so in Muhammad's time
the Bible was good it was authentic
after Muhammad that's when the changes
came about cool guess what guess what
you know wait you know in the Quran
there are verses that say there are
people that misinterpreted and forgot
the Bible you're right there's people
that misinterpret they don't see they
don't corrupt the text but they
misinterpret the text right yes okay I I
retract me saying that it got corrupted
before Muhammad's time but what I'm okay
what I'm saying is that it got
misinterpreted and forgotten and with
the misinterpretation and the lack of
remembrance of the Bible there was
supposed Muhammad came down to clarify
and send the last Revelation all right I
can settle for that right there now okay
let's let's let's let's let's show the
implications of what this means all
right so since the Bible according to
Muhammad is authentic in his time but
maybe Corruptions came after his time
here's the actual the actual scriptures
themselves but the people that I'm with
you I'm with you the actual scriptures
are actually good and preserved in
Muhammad's time they're authentic
they're good depending scriptures you
you talk about but but what what
Muhammad the Torah and the gospel simple
the Torah and the gospel the Bible the
Bible that's there no the Bible the
Bible that's what the Bible is the Bible
is a collection of Tor the gospel all
these okay all right so but I I'll I'll
I'll not say Bible I I'll stay specific
and stay and say Torah and gospel no no
let's stick with the Bible because the
Bible is what like I know more of than
the Torah but well the Torah is in the
Bible That's what I'm saying okay okay
continue what's what's the point you're
trying to make all right so the point
I'm making here is we we hit gold the
the Torah and the gospel the Bible in
Muhammad's time he believed it was
authentic he believed it was good
beautiful now here's the thing we have
the Bible the Torah and the gospel that
existed even before Muhammad's time so
not only do we have seventh century
manuscripts we also have 6th Century 4th
Century 3D Century 2 Century manuscripts
of the and and even beyond that of the
Torah because the Torah is older so we
have even older than that of the actual
Torah there there are fra there are
fragments and pieces and Y there's
fragments there's pieces we even have
whole manuscripts we have whole
manuscripts too be from before
Muhammad's time so that means that what
we have Muhammad believed it was
authentic we we have what is in
Muhammad's time and before so if there
was scripture that was corrupted
afterwards but we have the manuscripts
that are before
that there is a clear difference between
the English translation of the Bible
because logically speaking here we're
not talking about English translations
bro no no no but I'm going to come to my
point logically speaking here the Hebrew
the first Bible was in Hebrew right the
Torah the Old Testament is in Hebrew
yeah is in Hebrew after Muhammad's time
throughout throughout time it got
translated to Greek am I right yeah it
got translated to Greek so between the
Hebrew and the Greek do you think there
that was actually that sorry I misheard
your your question that actually
happened before Muhammad's time this
it's called the sepan is the Greek
translation of the Hebrew Old Testament
happened way before the point I'm trying
to make is the translations that are
that keep happening will will if you
keep like translating over and over and
over throughout time the the meanings
and the I guess understandings of the
original Bible will get lost nope it
didn't and especially not to Muhammad to
Muhammad it didn't get lost after
Muhammad's time not before sorry okay so
forget that then I'm talking about
before Muhammad's time we have what was
there before Muhammad's time so so we
have what Muhammad thought was authentic
that's my point okay yeah well what you
mean okay you have it then that doesn't
mean anything yes it does me it means
that Muhammad what I have right here
Muhammad believed in this right here
that I'm holding Muhammad believed in it
now here's the problem since what I what
I'm holding is authentic Muhammad
believed in it when I read it Muhammad
says this is true when I read it mhm I
read for example let's go how you know
how do you know that's the Bible that
that that is before Muhammad's time
because we have manuscripts of it before
Muhammad's time but but what if there
are you see clear contradictions and
mistakes then that would mean that
Muhammad is believing in a book full of
contradictions no that's not what I mean
I'm saying I'm saying that's how do you
know that is the the the rations the
reason how I know that this is it is
because we have the manuscripts we have
manuscript evidence textural tradition
and oral tradition that attests to the
scriptures we have today now if you're
saying that the scriptures that we have
are full of contradictions then you have
to say that Muhammad thought that a book
full of of contradictions was authentic
I know you don't want to say that no
because that doesn't make sense because
something that's after Muhammad's time
is so you're saying that the Bible has
been preserved yes so something that's
been that's been changed isn't preserved
so this has been changed but if in one
chapter in one chapter it says one thing
and in another chapter it said
something sh Shere you keep running into
the same problem if you're I'm allowing
you to do it if you want to say that
there's contradictions in the Bible then
you have to say that Muhammad believed
in a book full of contradictions I was
say his I guess say that again I said
without his complete knowledge like but
get get get to your original Point
that's so maybe Muhammad and now that's
actually a good point here guys because
because Muhammad is not allk knowing
right right right so Muhammad may not
have been aware he didn't know what he
was saying really he didn't he didn't
know what was in these books he just
belied that these books were authentic
without knowing what's in there is is
that fair to say okay no no I'm not
saying that but well this what you're
saying you're saying maybe not to his
knowledge no I said maybe but doesn't
mean it's a clear it's a clear on what
I'm saying all right so I'm just letting
you know what that maybe is when you say
maybe you didn't know about it then
you're saying give your original point I
was trying to say your original point I
mean okay so the the original point is
is that the Bible that we have Muhammad
believes so you can't say it has
contradictions you can't say it has any
problems but but the Bible itself the
one just breaking down the Bible itself
saying that there are there's three Gods
the the Holy Spirit nobody says there's
three Gods the Bible doesn't say there's
three Gods the Bible says there's one
God over and over again what are you
talking about but how can Jesus the the
Holy Spirit and the father be one
because there's one Divine Essence one
infinite Divine Essence that has three
persons that's God we're talking about
the nature of God so all right this is
this is okay let me let me let me get
you let me understand you completely
before before before try to understand
before you try to understand my Doctrine
if the Bible if the Bible is teaching
that God is a trinity then mammad is
authenticating a book that says God is
Triune then no that doesn't make sense
because in the Quran itself it says it
says Jesus isn't a isn't a God I know
what you're gonna say what am I gonna
say listen wait wait wait wait what am I
going to say I want to know if you if
you know I was going to say what am I
going to say you're going to say then
the the there's a clear cont between the
Quran and the Bible well that's true but
does that mean now if the Quran is
contradicting what the Bible says when
it says the Bible is true what does that
mean you're close bro you're so close
what does it mean if the Quran says the
Bible's true but contradicts the Bible
contradicts something that's true what
does that mean about the Quran in your
logic you're saying the the Quran is is
not the word of God the Quran would be
false but this is this is what what
you're you're not understanding we don't
there is no clear proof that Jesus was
said that he was God yes there is there
is it yeah I'll show you it but once I
show you it I'm gonna show you it and
hopefully like Shar so far you've been
you've been honest so I I believe I
believe in you man I believe wait
because I'm trying I'm trying to like
this this is what you're not
understanding wait let me let me do this
for you can I show you where Jesus
claimed to be God in the Bible yes okay
all right who's the first and the last I
I don't know the Bible as as like no no
the Quran who's the first and the last
Allah God that's right it's one of his
99 Names the first and the last that's a
name only for God Alone same thing in
the Bible in the Old Testament it says
that Yahweh that's the name of God
Yahweh he's the first and the last right
so Jesus himself he says in Revelation
The Book of Revelation chapter 1 verse1
17 he says to John do not be afraid I am
the first and the last the living one
what about when Jesus says don't pray
well he never says that he never says
don't pray to me he never says
that you're moving you're moving again
right
here okay right here Jesus when he says
he's the first and the last the living
one he's claiming to be God
right right uh if first and the last can
I can I see the scripture itself sure
I'll show you the scripture but let just
answer this if Jesus is saying that he's
the first and the last he's claiming to
be God right the first and the last like
with with your definition may but you
mean with my definition there's only one
the first and last means you're the
Eternal one right you're the Eternal one
you've ever you're Everlasting it's a
name only for God Alone we already just
said that doesn't that contradict when
the it doesn't you're bringing another
argument before you bring try to bring
objections please acknowledge it first
yes yes I acknowledge I acknowledge what
you're saying okay so Jesus claims to be
God here so it's Revelation 1 verse 17
all right it says here well I don't feel
like turning off my turning around my
screen is it okay if I just read it yeah
okay so it says so this is John speaking
he says when I saw him I fell at his
feet as though dead but he laid his
right hand on me saying fear not I am
the first and the last the living one so
we have clear statement in the bible
where jesus claims to be God now wait
wait wait wait let me let me rebuttal
that before you go into anything else
because you can't make us you can't make
a with i meing i no I thought we agreed
on this already no I agree what you said
yes logically speaking yes that's right
but when it comes down to the scripture
itself when Jesus said when Jesus said
there come after me he that is migher
than I am what does that mean Jesus
never said that that's John saying that
about Jesus John the Baptist Yahya is
saying the one that comes after me is
mightier than I he's talking about Jesus
well where Jesus's gospel repeat that
please for me so you're referring to
Mark 1 Mark 1:7 where Jesus says that's
not Jesus not Jesus that's John the
Baptist look look I'll read it to you
we'll start at verse we'll start at
verse verse six now John was clothed
with camel's hair and wore a leather
belt around his waist and ate locusts
and wild honey and he preached saying so
John preached saying after me comes he
who is mightier than I the strap of
whose sandals I'm not worthy to stoop
down and untie I have baptized you with
water but he will baptize you with the
Holy Spirit verse n in those days Jesus
came in those days Jesus came from
Nazareth of Galilee and was baptized by
John in the Jordan and when he came up
out the water immediately he saw the
heavens o being turned open and the
spirit descending on him like a dove and
a voice from heaven saying you are my
beloved Son with you I am well
pleased so that was John talking about
Jesus before he came okay finish your
point please the other point right right
so Jesus claims to be God in the Bible
now we know that the Quran says that
Jesus is not a god he's not a God right
he's just man if you know just like his
mother right says that sah chapter 5 now
here's the problem the Quran says that
the Bible is true but the the Bible says
that Jesus is God and the Quran
contradicts that but the Quran doesn't
doesn't believe that the the the Quran
doesn't believe that Jesus was God I
know that's what I just said that's what
I just said no if the Quran wait if the
Quran believe Crown believes that the
Bible is true but does it doesn't say
the the complete Bible is true
oh I had hope in you man no because
because let me explain to you you're
you're basically saying you're saying
nope you're saying that the old the
older
Bible let me show let me let me show you
what the Quran says about what you just
said dude the Quran answers you on all
of this I don't have to say anything the
Quran gives you a response to everything
you guys say so you said the Quran is
saying some parts of it is good while
some parts may not be good let me show
you what the Quran says about people who
have that thought here's chapter 2 verse
85 watch chapter 2 verse 85 listening
after this it is you who kill or un
alive one another and drive out a party
of you from their homes and assist their
enemies against them in sin and
transgression and if they come to you as
captives you Ransom them although their
exposion was forbidden to you now watch
this this is relevant to you sh then do
you believe in part of the scripture and
reject the
rest then what is the recompense the the
the result of those who do so among you
accept disgrace in this life of this
world and on the day of Resurrection
they shall be consigned to the most
Grievous torment what I'm rejecting is
the the Trinity I'm reting you can
reject the Trinity all you want but you
can't say that some part of the
scripture is good while the other is not
because the Quran says those who do that
are disgraced in this life and will be
punished in the next I'm talking about
the scripture
CU in the Old Testament it does not
clearly mention the Trinity you can say
that all you want I can show you that it
does but that's that's neither here nor
there here's the point here's the point
bro the point is this is that the Quran
says the Bible's true and you can't
believe in some part of it while
rejecting other parts of it you got to
believe in all the scripture or else
you're going to be disgraced so you
can't do that so this is the problem and
this is where the Islamic dilemma is the
Quran says that the Bible's true however
let me let me I'm trying to land this sh
been trying I'll let you I'll let you go
the Quran says that the Bible is true
but it contradicts the Bible so then
that means that the Quran is false since
it contradicts what is true now let's
say that the Bible's false if the
Bible's false then the Quran is still
false because the Quran says that this
false book is true if the Bible's not
true when the Quran says it's true then
the Quran is false for lying saying that
the Bible is true when it's not so
either way it doesn't work if the
Bible's true the Quran is false because
the Quran contradicts the Bible if the
Bible's false the Quran is still false
because the Quran said that this false
book is true it's a double-edged sword I
get your point but it it doesn't it
doesn't explain the just before you say
anything just what is this guy gonna say
in response to what I say just think
about it no because you're using you're
using to justify the Bible you you're
using the Quran and I'm saying that
you're only using your your you're only
using the Quran to justify the Bible in
certain cases but when no I'm not but
when the Quran rejects the Bible in
certain cases when the Quran says Jesus
is not God you don't accept that well
that's because the Quran says my book is
true so if the Quran if when the Bible
says Jesus Is God and the Quran says
Jesus is not God then that means the
Quran is false because it's
contradicting what it said is true it's
the quran's fault not mine no no no I
agree with you one thing you're missing
here the the the yes the Quran says the
Bible is true yes and the cases where
the Quran says Jesus is not God that's
not true it's still true it in itself
because it can be yeah because because
in the in the Old Testament the Trinity
Doctrine is not explicitly like
explained or mentioned you running to
that doesn't help you once again I'm not
I'm not running to it I'm I'm
clearly toward the gospel say that Jesus
is God the the Old Testament says the
same thing it doesn't matter where you
go the the it says Jesus Is God if it
says Jesus Is God but the Quran
contradicts that then the Quran is false
because it says that the book is true
that's the quran's Dilemma the Quran is
contradicting a book it says is true but
you you know why I'm I'm mentioning the
the Old Testament here the Trinity sorry
is because look I just looked it up here
it says no Trinity Doctrine is
explicitly taught in the Old Testament I
don't care what you looked up dude I
don't care what you looked up because no
no because you're you're saying that
since the the Quran says this is not
true then I'm saying what the Quran says
is true is true what the Quran says is
is also true is true not saying that
Jesus is not God is true due
to I'll ask you one last time as as we
went over let's be let's make sure we
hold unto honesty and integrity we read
earlier in the ver in in the verse in
the Bible that Jesus claimed to be right
I don't think it's the Old Testament I'm
in the Bible it doesn't have to be the
Old Testament so if it's in the Old
Testament that's rap if if if it says
that Jesus is God in the Old Testament
it's over
right if if it mentions if it if it like
clearly mentions the the the Trinity if
it no if it says that Jesus is God in
the Old Testament the quran's over with
right no if if it clearly mentions the
Trinity because I'm does does the Quran
mention the Trinity does the Quran
mention the Trinity yes no where where
does the Quran mention no no logically
speaking if you're mentioning God and
the father is God and Jesus as as God
the Quran doesn't mention father at all
matter of fact it says that Allah has no
children yeah that's the point like
you're using you're using
no let's stay to the coure because we're
wasting time yeah if the Old Testament
said that Jesus is God then that's it
for the Quran right because you've been
holding on to the Old Testament you saw
in the New Testament Jesus Is God but
you're like well
well the Old Testament doesn't have that
so the Quran is still cool so if the if
the Old Testament said that Jesus is God
then the Quran is it's over with for the
Quran right not necessarily but then
stop holding on to that stop using that
as a fake criteria if that's not what it
is then stop holding it onto it as a
fake criteria to try to put a bandage in
the Quran let's be real to with each
other so the Bible says Jesus is God the
Quran says Jesus is not God the Quran
says the Bible is true the Quan
contradicts the Bible so then the Quran
is false with that logic I I see how you
came to that conclusion thank you but I
I will still disagree maybe what are you
disagreeing with I'm disagreeing I'm
disagreeing on the idea of I la the
knowledge to understand but you don't
yes I I don't know the Quran in and out
and I don't know the Bible In and Out
means I know I know it in and out as I'm
showing you know you don't know the
Quran no come on come on now you don't
know the Quran in and out why why why
you telling me I don't know the Quran in
I'm literally showing you the Quran in
and out because because because because
Scholars take years of their lives
understanding and it took it took years
it took years of my life too it took
years of my life but to understand the
authentic do you do you speak Arabic I
don't have to I'm an English I'm English
okay we're arguing about something
that's besides the point but I'm just
saying that I I would with your with
your conclusion that you're coming to I
understand how you see that you you have
the you have the understanding to
understand my Logic No no but I I I I
reject it because I believe that I don't
have the knowledge enough knowledge to
be able to give you a rebuttal like this
is the first me no no come on there's
always a rebuttal but there's time of me
this is the first time of me I'm just um
first time of me understanding that
Muhammad believed that the Bible at his
time wasn't corrupted so I'll give it to
you but I but I won't accept it due to
the fact that I'm not that well versed
all right so this is what I will say in
response to what you just said because
what you just gave is a humble position
which I appreciate however I don't
appreciate the you you're playing
yourself because share out of all the
people that I've spoken to over the past
three days you have been top three when
it comes to being able to understand a
logical conversation and understand
points with you I've been able to get
from point A to point D It's very rare
that I can do that so you're playing
yourself when you say I don't have the
understanding to or the knowledge to be
able to actually accept your
position The Logical no The Logical
knowledge I I haven't I I understand I
know how to understand a logical process
or process sorry but the scripture
itself because if we focus on certain
phrases certain scriptures in one page
and neglect the whole book itself then
that's that's incompetent because I
rather take I rather take the
understanding of the whole book itself
with that scripture than the scripture
the the verse sorry let me let me
rephrase that I rather take the
understanding of the whole book and the
verse rather than just the verse does
that make sense yeah would you like to
see what the whole Quran says about this
I can give you like I know it's kind of
late probably I don't know where you're
from maybe it's early but for me it's a
little I'm in I'm in I'm in Jersey right
now but oh you're on the East Coast Okay
so is late for you yeah but but I can I
can show you if if you if you stay in
touch with me bro I can show you all the
verses in the Quran that talk about the
previous scriptures I can show you it
all this is the thing this is the thing
I don't believe that you understand the
Quran as much as you think you do
because even the Arabic understanding of
the Quran is not the same he doub one
second you're doubting me one second
brother one second one one second you
doubted me one second there are Scholars
one
second St at me guys what are you going
to show me now I'm going to show you
what other Muslims say I'm going to show
you what Muslims say about me okay no
I'm just I'm just what I'm trying to
point out is no I rather have a I rather
have a Muslim that's more knowledgeable
than I am rebuttal these points why
would you rather have a Muslim when a
Muslim is going to lie to you and tell
you the same lies that you need at first
okay I didn't believe no no lies you did
you you believed that the the Quran
thought that the scriptures were
corrupted you believe Li it was just
misformation I I I know that's what I'm
saying these the Muslims that you will
go to are going to give you the same
misinformation come with yourself I did
it was a logical deduction no you didn't
come up with this yourself your your
your imams and the people around you
told you that the Bible's been corrupted
been changed and even even the Quran has
this view of the Bible they lied to you
brother brother brother brother listen
listen to what I'm saying okay I'm
saying that I rather a more
knowledgeable person about Islam have
have these points gone that's me I'm
that guy not because because you are not
a Muslim I don't have to be a Muslim to
be knowledgeable about Islam as you can
see you do you do you no I don't don't
you see that I know the Quran that I
know what I'm talking about trust me
brother you don't know the Quran then
you don't know the Quran cover to cover
you know the Quran cover I know I know
the Quran like the back of my thigh
brother please but but I like the point
what I can give you on I like the point
the the the the debate tactic you use is
to justify the Bible by the Quran that
was yeah why why would I waste my time
doing what the Quran has already done
for me especially if I'm talking to a
Muslim the Quran has already done the
work for me so I don't have to do
anything all I got to do is just read
look what what hey audience guys
what's hold on let me address the the
audience real quick hey guys Shar is new
here what what's the only thing we do
here guys what what's the only thing we
do here look at the com look at the look
at the comments they'll tell you what we
do we just read man that's all I do I
don't interpret I don't add I don't take
away we just read that's all I got to do
no you you're not just reading don't
don't don't downplay yourself like that
what what what what you're doing is is
validating certain points
by the Quran you're making your points
but I don't know enough to be able to
dive into those points that's a lie I
don't trust me I do not I'm not I'm not
as knowledgeable as you think I am maybe
logically yes I understand the a logical
process itself all right I found it I
want you to listen to this okay so this
is what a Muslim remember my name is
Avery this is what a Muslim this is what
a Muslim says about me listen Avery
knows more things about Islam than me
and than than a lot of people in this
room a lot of people in the whole world
all right let me let me just one more
time in case you do knows more things
about Islam than me and than you than a
lot of people in this room a lot of
people in the whole War one more time
just for good I like but that doesn't
prove anything on it's a Muslim you say
you like to hear from Muslims these are
these are Muslims listen No but I rather
hear from a a a Muslim that's more
knowledgeable than you are that oh
that's that's going to be tough to find
that's going to be tough no there are
multiple it's not it's not tough to find
like a Muslim Muslim more knowledgeable
than me of course Good Luck Good Luck
look listen to this knows more things
about Islam than me and than you than a
lot of people in this room a lot of
people in the whole world that's a
Muslim saying that I know more about the
Islam than most Muslims in the world
it's not me I don't I can say the same
thing about Christianity brother say say
that again I could say the same thing
about Christianity that's not a point
what do you mean I'm get it the point
I'm trying to make is the exception does
not make the rule what I'm trying to say
is you knowing more than an average
Muslim does not prove to me that you
have the knowledge to answer the
questions or not even questions but the
the arguments that I have because if if
the Muslims are tell are saying to each
other now by the way there this is in a
in a room on stage a group of Muslims
are telling other Muslims why they
should not come to me and it's not
because I'm a hater it's not because I'm
deceitful it's not because you know I
have sneak tactics it's because I know
more about Islam than most Muslims in
the world and if they come to me then
they will get doubts they will get
shahat because I'm G to teach them the
truth I'm not doubting My Religion like
but I'm not saying you are I'm not
saying you are but your your a seed has
been planted to now you have a different
perspective now at least you know what
I'm saying you're not necessarily
doubting a religion however you have
been introduced to A New Perspective
that actually logically makes sense no
the perspective that that's been
introduced to was that using the the
before after the Muhammad time before
the revelations came down I don't know
enough about the Bible to to to have an
argument with you because all you all
you need to do is know about the Quran
just know what the Quran says I disagree
I I I I completely disagree yes the
Quran says everything is true but I
don't know enough about the Bible in
that time to be able to justify what the
Quran said all right so this what I this
what I'll do and I and I'll move on to
the next person I I want to I want you
to keep coming back like keep watching
my lives cuz I do I'm live almost every
day bro brother I'm too busy brother you
literally like you randomly call me oh
so okay well whenever whenever you know
just if you I'll probably I'll probably
be back like maybe if I have I'll brush
up on my Christianity between Muhammad's
time between before Muhammad's time this
is this is what you should look into
okay do we have manuscripts of the Bible
before Muhammad's time look into that
I'm not disagreeing with that what I'm
going to look into is the the comparison
between those manuscripts and what's
available today okay good enough that
that's also good that between those
times because which wait I have a
question for you is there is there a
clear difference between certain CH
certain denominations um doctrinally but
we use the same
text so all denominations of Christians
Christians I'm not talking about sexs
that claim to be Christian and are not
I'm not talk like Jehovah's Witnesses or
morm they're not Christians talking
about actual Christians Catholics
Orthodox Christians Ethiopian Christians
Coptic Christians Protestants all of
these groups of Christianity they all
believe in the Trinity they all believe
in the death burial and resurrection of
Jesus Christ they all believe in the
Salvation that Jesus Christ offers
through his atonement through his blood
sacrifice but there are certain there
are certain like things that they
disagree upon yes there are certain
things that they disagree on which is
what you know puts them into the groups
that they are in however the core
tenants of the faith they all hold on to
they all believe that God is Triune they
all believe that Jesus is the Divine Son
of God the Father Who Came In the Flesh
died for our sins according to the flesh
was buried and rose again on the third
day right we all believe that we all
have the core values and beliefs there
are other doctrines you know that we'll
disagree on but we have the same core
values of beliefs that hold us under the
umbrella of Christendom as being a
Christian so and do you follow the pope
no real quick could you explain that to
me the difference between the Pope the
church is it too long it's it's it's
long and and I wouldn't be the person
qualified to break that stuff down for
you all right but no there is all right
thank you very much it's been an amazing
conversation yeah it's been awesome man
I appreciate you all right brother ay
yes Avery all right have a good day you
too man